question for you Benedict's presumably
role like this playing Alan Turing comes
with a strong sense of responsibility
not just to do a good job as ever but
when you're telling a lie for some of
the life of someone who's been wronged
to put it lightly by history there's an
extra weight there oh shoot I think so
that the sort of disparity between his
importance and prevalence in our modern
culture as well as what he achieved in
the 20th century and the comparative
lack of knowledge of the full span of
his story in life I mean there's a
fantastic film which I film of the play
breaking the code which I saw and I
think I was taught some variation of
what went on at Bletchley Park and his
name was mentioned but the idea of
getting a broader story out there and
brought a picture of him to a broader
audience was is obviously something that
does bear a certain weight of importance
and yeah it's it's his legacy you know
this has been an extraordinary decade
for him because of Pardons because of
his centenary because of exhibitions and
books and and and now this film so it's
part of a momentum I hope to have him at
the forefront of the recognition he
deserves as a scientist as a computer a
father of the modern computer age and a
war hero and a man who lived an
uncompromising life in a time of
disgusting discrimination contextualised
obviously by the fear of God you know
the red threat but still without without
them that's not an excuse for what
happened to him and and to also try and
on a sort of a personal note examine
something that's not very well
documented I mean he physically there's
no medium of him there's no ironically
considering what he was about there's no
maybe not maybe not because of the
secrecy but he was you know there's no
oral recording there's no visual or
audio recording of him so there's a huge
wait yes it's a blank canvas to an
extent so you have a bit of freedom but
it's yeah you're toying with something
you have nothing to bounce off with as a
reflection
so I just I worked out from Graham's
brilliant script and Morton and I
specially Morton's research and what he
told guided me towards and and the
people I was lucky enough to meet you
either met him or related to him and
however long ago it was in their life
story they they gave me accounts that
were helpful to personalize this
extraordinary man whose achievements we
know in a sort of broad headline turn
but be more specific about who he was
moment to moment in our story grave I
know that Allen cheering for you was a
has been a personal hero for a long long
time I've heard you say that you were
your self confessed self confessed
science and that as a teenager so you I
mean you obviously had a strong idea
this this was a story it needed to be
told that doesn't necessarily translate
to the film business assuming of
agreeing and this is a story that should
be told for a broad audience as Benedict
says but was there a mountain to climb
there at all
persuading people it should be made yeah
I mean I you know I've been obsessed
with the story of Alan Turing since I
was a teenager and I was lucky enough as
a teenager to get to know the story and
to get to sort of be aware of the story
of this tremendous person who
accomplished all these things that no
one knew about and I'd always you know
as a fan of films I'd always wanted to
see I always want to see an Alan Turing
movie I'd always wanted to see his story
told as Benedict said had been told so
well on the page and on the stage before
but no one had ever done with a proper
cinematic treatment of it and it was
always sort of insane to me like how
come no one has made it made a film
about Turing he's such an amazing
fascinating character and and as an
audience member right I created I think
I just to get this movie made I would
have been a I would have been a PA on
the set of the imitation game if I
wasn't the writer I'm so glad that I got
to have that job you know it was such a
it's a it's an honor to get to have been
a part of bringing you know a story to a
much broader audience Kira but Benedict
was saying that Alan Turing we despite
his fame there was the very little
documentation little or no recordings of
him Joan Clarke sobs he less well known
but we were there were there sources you
control you were able to through and
beyond
Graham script and there was
that there's an interview that she gave
which Martin told me about which is
online which I mean she what she was
probably what in her mid 70s late 70s
you know um so so yes I watched that and
certainly took I think that call that
quality of sort of that quiet sort of
very very nice very sort of feminine
sort of person I thought that was really
interesting I liked the idea that you
know she was absolutely somebody who was
sort of breaking boundaries in her own
right but she didn't go about it like a
bull in a china shop
you know she sort of didn't see her
coming and I got that from from the
interviews that she gave and also the
sort of the great friendship and love
that existed between her and Alan you
could really feel that in the interview
that I saw you know there was still she
was so protective of him even talking
about him but but I mean relatively
speaking there's very little given given
how important she was there's very
little to go on more than I'm sure you
share or I was feeding this is a story
that needs to be told but in film terms
for you why did you what did you want to
do it what grabbed you about about
making it I mean when I when I read the
script I was shocked how align your body
before it's you know why wasn't he on
the front cover of the history book when
I was at school and maybe I mean I was I
just moved to Hollywood I was an
outsider in Hollywood and to me this is
a movie about outsiders about those who
are you know different who think outside
the norm and and there was something
about a story that really struck me and
I was reading a lot of scripts which
were action trailers and superhero
movies and all that and then come this
period British movie and I just became
obsessed with it it's such a it felt
such an important and beautiful story
and he hasn't had it's just an unsung
hero who achieved so much and it's also
this great human element of this this is
this man who didn't fit in who was you
know ahead of his time outside of his
time and was carrying all his secrets
his layers and layers of secrets how you
know his sexuality how he was you know
as a
petition was came almost it's like
spying super spying in mobile mi6 with
all the six units and it's it's both in
character level and understory level
it's it became something I just needed
to do and it's and I'm feel very
privileged in r2 to try and spread it
you know the legacy in the world of
home-tree thank you let's start taking
questions when we wait for the
microphone if you can please please tie
your hands up and we'll move across the
room so if you can start down here as a
gentleman in the specs three rows back
thanks thank you
Espen or norwegian broadcasting too
until you I don't know if they can ask
you to annoy someone by answering partly
in and Weejun I let you decide that how
is it going to show you feelings on this
day opening the Film Festival with such
a film it really actually it's a little
bit like coming home for the movie in a
weird way I mean I mean it's it was shot
here in London and it was very important
for us to to to shoot it here and to
shoot it as as many locations as
possible where things happen be sure
that legislate we started at the school
where Alan Turing went to a short born
and in many ways it is our Norwegian
coming in here and I came it with a lot
of respect for the culture and for the
story which would tell me this is an
important part of British history and I
wanted to get it right and it's say I
can't wait for tonight it's a great
honor and it's a and it's very thrilling
to come here and show the film to the
British audience so so it's going to be
a great night can you do better than
Norwegian that I can translate for
everybody you to better that Norwegian
entrancing oh no it's in its and I
actually have to say I've been so well
received I mean it's I was singing okay
so I got this phenomenal top British
talent and everybody said yes to be a
part of this and here comes there's no
Weejun and it's going to you know tell
this this important story and it and I
would say it's been the whole thing has
been just such a pleasurable experience
and it's been so well received here so
I'm very thankful thank you is there a
question around here there's one down
there
his microphone please thank you hello if
I choose your bathroom you have Czech
Republic I have a question for mr.
combat since the movie opened there's
the Oscar talking about it for you that
you will get the Oscar nomination so
does it bother you or how do you
perceive this Oscar game well you know
if it gets people to see the film
frankly this is really is all I care
about
and it's very early on it's very
flattering of course but there are a lot
of other extraordinary films and
performances that people haven't seen
yet or are also talking about so it's a
far way off but if it creates an
interest for people to see this film and
what the fuss is about then that's
fantastic because it means our jobs as
storytellers is made easier if there's
an audience for our storytelling and
more importantly for me having sort of
had some experience with this
extraordinary man I really want his
story to be known as broadly as possible
and I found to be a launching point for
more interest and understanding of him
and the proper celebration of him of a
maturing so from that point of view it's
good
thank you there was a question a couple
of rows behind there please yeah thanks
hi this is Frank Johnson brigand
newspaper in Norway just a follow-up to
the other Norwegian guy's question just
adjust to the actor to the actress
because this is a very British story
told by Adam Eaton director did he
surprise you by shooting or before
shooting or was there something fresh
she brought to the script or to the film
talking to Benedict and oh sorry Keira
know about him being Norwegian yeah no
no about the did he surprise here during
the is Norwegian the process this has
ability today a sensibilities never I
thought it was a very very cool very
intelligent very smart fit to bring a
man who had brought an incredibly
entertaining a really dark thriller to
all of our attention last year a year
before two years ago yes
yeah but you know he proved his
brilliance with that and the idea of
combining that talent on something that
had a massive thriller component but
also the minute I met him I realized how
astute he was as is actually borne out
with with his with headhunterz with
character study it is all about
character study but you weren't invested
in a thriller unless you care about the
characters so I was thrilled when we
talked to me god I'm really really well
we both shared a passion for the
subjects having engaged with the script
and and discovered more about this man
than we had before and being ashamed of
that like I I was the same as moss and
why isn't this man on on some
denomination of our currency why isn't
he on the front cover of science
textbooks history textbooks so I yeah I
was thrilled and and day by day you know
he's got an extraordinary energy and
even when he's a lot of caffeine and
even when he's over caffeinated and you
know I some of my stutter was often
modeled on Morton we had a wonderful
script supervisor called Beverly and
sometimes just Beverly's name would just
come out as a edit that was it that was
really good because he was on to the
next thought you know but it's a great
energy to have and it's and I'm teasing
him but it was he was very specific in
his direction very highly attuned to all
the turns and twists and the immediate
circumstances where we were in the store
in contextualizing any moment so you
know you need that you need that when
you're telling an important story you
need a really strong director not just
with energy but with intelligence and
wit and we got him so um you know I knew
from the first meeting it was going to
be a right to work with him and it
really was thank you anyone is not
Norwegian
maybe I'm going to go towards the back
there's a lady in a stripy jumper there
and of some of the camera as well if we
can do those two please Thanks thanks
I'm Dagmara
from Poland and has published journals I
have to ask this question because every
time there is a film about enigma and in
Poland there's a question will Delta
tell about our input there isn't much of
it in this film because this is a
character-driven story but I was
wondering have you thought about putting
moral polish in
into the Enigma solution for the
director and for the screenwriter I'd
like just both of you
the comment tears I can see quickly
there's two references to it I mean
we're aware of the polish achievement
and and we wanted to acknowledge that by
by its referenced twice and in the film
I mean it's a lot we can talk about for
an hour but you know that's the how the
Enigma was the Polish work was based on
the the early version of the Enigma and
how that enigma was changed when the war
started and the and the German army
started to use it so so in many ways was
accurate that the work was foundation
that in many way it didn't help them at
Bletchley so much because the Enigma was
so fundamentally changed so Allen's
in many way I have to start over again
he had to start from scratch with the
work so so if we wanted to acknowledge
it and I think we have done that in the
in the film what had a great deal about
that oh yeah no I think everything
Morton said is is absolutely right and
there's there's two references and two
scenes Benedict's character makes
references to the Polish contribution
and and certainly he had looked at the
Polish bombs and used those as a model
for the ones that the Turing had created
at Bletchley Park so we want to just rip
a tribute to to the Polish work and show
of what the mathematicians and
scientists at Bletchley were able to
build on top of that I guess I'm first
of all congratulations on an absolutely
beautiful piece of cinema my questions
to Benedict's
Benedict as someone who's made such an
extraordinary success of playing a
socially abrasive heroic genius on our
small screens in recent years I'm
curious when you're approaching this
role did you feel a certain pressure to
inject Allen with nuances and
personality traits that distinguished
him from Sherlock and given the lack of
source material available where did you
look for for that wonderful inspiration
well I mean I'm limited by Who I am and
what I looked like but at the same time
that utterly different people so yes of
course and I think I did you know he
doesn't swish around in a coat with
curly hair
demonstrating how brilliant he is she's
a very quiet stoic determined difference
and and evident hero and I think someone
who yeah he's he's smart but I think the
way that he has to operate as an
outsider and as someone who is at all
different is something that was very
much out of the conditions of his life
and he you know as far as another
similarity that he's socially awkward
what you see is a whole evolution in him
which is humanizing and that happens I
suppose in some aspects of what we do
with our version of Sherlock but now I
didn't read the scripts and go oh this
is Sherlock in Tweed fiddling around
with valves and wires you know I like
the Whizzer bit I liked how
uncompromising he was and I suppose that
is that is a strong trait I think but
that's a strong trait in strong
characters and they always have a
traction practice of of every variety so
I yeah you find us played stupid people
as well I want to point on that I mean
I've any one's got some more stupid
roles out there for me great bring him
on but um it's um you know it's a great
honour to be asked to play somebody like
uninsurance oh the last thing I'm going
to do is go well yeah but you know it's
a bit like Sherlock isn't it because
it's then it's not it's really not and
you can't begin to fathom you know what
an individual is if you start just
categorizing them as having similarities
to other characters you've played and I
do try to shake it up but I do see why
people think that too clever people
might have similarities but yeah and you
find those comparisons frustrating or
understandable at no I don't know I
understand I mean yeah the frustrating
but I do understand them of course I do
of course I do I to watch stuff
so question there they are this side
gentlemen there where your hand around
thank you hi there Vincent IB BC world
service air for Kira really turns a very
strange character in many ways I suppose
we'd now say autistic did you come to a
conclusion as to what his character was
because he's in many ways very hard to
read I'm not saying in the film but in
real life I didn't think autistic I
didn't get that from it um I didn't get
that look um no did I get a read on on
what he was like from so did you come to
a conclusion as to what kind of man he'd
been in real life um no I just thought
he was what Benedict had gone for I mean
I I know I I thought it was a wonderful
characterization I thought it made
complete sense I'd read the same
biographies that Benedict had read and
and and obviously the same wonderful
script you know and I thought it made a
lot of sense I mean again we don't
actually know you know there aren't any
recordings as Ben's already said so so
who knows but I thought as a
characterization it was it was totally
beautiful and really got the essence of
what I felt I'd read from the source
material great would you like to pick up
on that autistic going there or the
suggestion that he was autistic or the
bend he was playing him as autistic yeah
I mean certainly that was a word that
didn't exist during his lifetime and I
think in general you know diagnosing
people 50 years after the fact gets gets
a little bit dangerous it was something
that was not a word that we ever used on
sad or in rehearsals certainly he's
someone who had a sense of sort of
social outside earnest he was not like
the people around him but I think that
was because Alan Turing was separated
from the world around him by so many
different things because he was one of
the great geniuses of the 20th century
because he was gay and closeted and
could you tell anyone about it because
the government was asking him to keep
all of these secrets he was sort of the
Outsiders outsider and I think that's
something we talked about image of
bringing that to life never seen I just
could when I did was a discussion we had
a lot of it also with Benedict and if he
didn't want to play any but we did want
to put him in a box I mean they did the
whole
theme the whole mission of the whole
movie is to celebrate uniqueness to
celebrate individual and you will have
individuality and and to put sort of
like a label on somebody is sort of the
opposite about this movie is trying to
do and you know it's then it becomes a
condition this is something curable
something that should between a specific
way he was just unique it was just you
know a character that thought in a
different way and and that is what we
wanted to celebrate that's what we
wanted to tell
thank you guys question down here please
thanks hi I'm Peyton from women talking
on my magazine and my question is for
mr. Knightley and it's you talked at the
start of the conference about how your
character Joan Clark was sort breaking
boundaries for for feminism would you
say yourself that you believe there's a
parallel between the era of the movie
and now what with this new wave of
modern feminism yeah sure I mean I mean
the actual journey clock what she was
fighting for was a place at the table in
equal pay and I think those are still
the two main things that feminists today
are fighting for and there's still
inequality in that so I definitely got
that from from the script and from
researching her I thought actually the
similarities were quite extraordinary
thank you that question here down the
front please hello Alessandra at the
Herald it's questions to Benedict
Cumberbatch you spoke about how the
assessment of Allen's ruling is changing
but why did it take so long until the
21st century for them to get that
recognition I don't know but I guess the
Official Secrets Act I guess the dark
stain of shame of the government's hand
in persecuting thousands of men for
their sexuality for fear of communist
sympathies I guess the idea that
somebody's work which in the
mathematical sphere pure math is is
devoid of for the larger part
geopolitical interest or any kind of
culture of celebrity or need for it
really about above and beyond funding
and that's keeping about a function in
that sphere means that you know the true
amalgamated importance of the man is his
life as well as his work and that's only
just slowly really become something that
people
knowledged I yeah what why couldn't why
the partners could have been earlier I
don't know I'm not the Queen or David
Cameron um
maybe those will be my next roles I he'd
like to see you basically how they seem
in that frock
oh yeah weird visions going through my
head yeah so no let's move on that no
but seriously I don't know I don't know
that I'm not going to decry it as being
a disgrace because I don't honestly know
the circumstances it would be very
interesting to investigate that and I'd
be interested if you did because you
know to me you know you immediately feel
a sense of injustice playing a man that
was treated as poorly as he was and
whose achievements had for so long been
overlooked or not conglomerated into the
fuller picture of who he was and what he
achieved that we're now getting to
understand and you know this is a film
when we touch upon those and it's a
thrilling story and it's funny it's a
film but I beg anyone who's at all
interested from what we presented him to
look further into his life his work at
Bletchley Park the biographies have been
written about him and the other
characters in the film Joan and Hugh and
can cross you know fascinating
characters all who played an incredible
part in being very quiet stoic heroes
aware as well as thousands of other men
and women who are nameless who some of
whom are still alive and still keep
their secrets even though they don't
have to anymore it's as much a
celebration of that as well but I think
that might be part of it as a society I
think if we've lived through a very
secretive area or shaming era we're very
good at sort of looking over things and
it's dangerous dangerous to do that
because the smell you know from
underneath the floorboards eventually is
impossible to ignore
and you know hopefully this will do
something to expose the truth of what
happened to the man and some truth of
the time as well thank you there's a
question here for labarie from news talk
in Ireland I just wondered a leech isn't
here today who played John Kane cross
and he's somewhere there Oh is he's in
the hotel alright okay where is he
could could Kira and bending maybe talk
a little bit about working with Alan I
don't know was it the first time both of
you worked with him first time I work
with him he's wonderful
I totally loved him he was as bad at
doing crosswords as I was I appreciated
that I loved leech is one of those
people you after five minutes you think
you've known him all of your life and
he's he's just a lovely around human
being a brilliant brilliant actor really
talented and incredibly supportive and
fun to be around and just yeah he makes
for a very good very good playing
companion yeah - thanks I can get the
Mike to the back of the room again
there's someone on the end of the road
there please Thanks yes right there
Thanks hi I'm Hannah blimp male online
and how much of the mass did you
actually understand who is the best out
of the class in applying the mask and
are you better sodoku now what was the
last part of question are you Barry
sodoku now what's that are you Barrett
seed okey now am I was better it's Doku
thank you I kind of in here so I'm gonna
be goodest okay no no no no we we had
one day we all thought oh yeah we should
really be doing crosswords so we brought
in like the quick quick crossword there
were five of us and it took us five days
and we still get proficient so no we're
really bad at all of it and I didn't
understand any of the math did you don't
say you did
opens up kind of trouble yeah that's why
I remember we were there we had this
specialized it was trying to describe
this wonderful machine Alan Turing god
bless you yeah Bletchley Park almost
always terribly nice face it's just how
many thousands of times you broaden you
had the all this expert and it was
flying and be just listening and then we
see this panic the eyes of everybody
were looking at it like this is this is
impossible is that feeling I haven't had
since school being in math so just like
you sort of feel that you've died and
there's no way to concentrate at all it
was that and I'm desperately fighting
coz he was such a nice man you go this
is really interesting I should be paying
attention
I couldn't there's a great broad romance
to the philosophy of maths and physics
which is dramatized these days which is
which is tangible hopefully because
otherwise there's no point in explaining
it all sharing it with an audience and I
think there are hugely exciting things
that on a base level everyone can
understand the idea of coding the idea
of programming the idea that what we use
as language can be turned into something
universal and could be used in a machine
here China Russia you know York wherever
and and those things excite me you know
the fact that my eyelashes carbon in it
from a star excites me I don't
necessarily understand everything about
how to make an eyelash
but it's the broad brushstrokes are very
appealing and I you know as far as the
Machine goes d-machine the bomb
Kristopher an arse but the bomb in
reality at Bletchley Park that was the
moment where I thought right now this
time this is very hard and and the guy
the guy Stanley Weiser took can you
explain to me just looked him you in
right so what we have here and use
Damien if you knew it was not just me
not just a stupid actor but also the
fact that every other person isn't
necessarily a pure math expert a
mechanical engineer or a combination of
the two these are incredibly complex
machines breaking down incredibly
complex problems at great high level and
sorry high place and high volume and you
know as I understood a little bit about
it I did understand it but I understood
a lot about the Enigma machine the
absolute coding machine and but yeah if
you put an algorithm in front of me now
I even a quadratic equation would have
this press conference going far too long
there should
we've got time for a couple more
questions please there's one if you just
keep the back there's one there very
baton in it by the pillar if I can take
that then we'll come in the middle
middle over here Thanks and Benjamin
from gay times and this is to Benedict I
was wondering how you approached
portraying Alan sexuality in its
subtleties and do it in a way that was
appropriate to that generation um his
sexuality is something that is contained
that is that is expressed in the film
but not shown explicitly by their is
their heterosexual ality expressed in
the film and so what we show that what
his better his behavior that towards his
sexualities is sadly true to the story
which is that he had to for a large part
suppress it make it private make it
something secret and when the cost of
sharing that information but also in
Alan's case being completely explicit
with it whether it's talking about you
know treating a young man to touch my
penis in the in the police interrogation
scene whether it's talking with my - one
like Allan leeches can cross thank you
let's talk about can cross confessing
his sexuality at the engagement party is
just to honor Alan one of complete
honesty of guileless honest of innocence
and and and and sort of to be aware of
the risks but at the same time not
willing to cave in to the intolerance or
the potential permutations of confessing
such a thing and I think I think that's
possibly where he stands I know lots of
people own him as a martyr or someone
who is a standard bearer for cause I
think he was just very true to himself
which i think is a form of martyrdom it
is but he didn't make a political
statement out of it it was it was a
personal thing for him and to remember
that he was physically active so his
sexuality was something that was
important that if his physicality was
important is his athleticism as well as
a run it was important and while it
turned out to be the most important
tragic strand
his story it is but one strand of his
character albeit an incredibly important
one so yeah it was really important to
me it was really important to me that we
got that element of it right and I think
in that time the conversations you hear
are incredibly explicit yeah that's what
about so the question so really we're
gonna have to wrap up the press copper
cell I just want to end by more than you
spoke earlier about how excited you are
to open the London Film Festival with
the imitation game Keira and bending
you're both sorry to exclude aggregor
you're both Londoners yeah I know I know
both of you attended the Film Fest
before what does it mean to both of you
to open this festival with this film go
okay oh it's amazing it's amazing it's
really amazing I mean yeah I'm a
Londoner and I've always wanted to spend
more time at the lff and to be a know to
be up front and center with this film I
couldn't be more proud of it and all of
all of our work in it and to present
that to London is is just terrific and
yeah I'm really really excited it means
a lot
ditto but good luck with the release
good luck with tonight and thank you
very much well four of you thank you oh
thank you
you